why would we want to eradicate
[Music]
Jews she was crying and she said I found
this verse in the Quran I've been so
worried about the Palestinian people and
especially the kids who've been dying
and it says here in the Quran but what
about if someone pushes back and says
hold on but aren't you the guys that are
saying from The River To The Sea knowing
Ians are doing everything that was
described job doing in the
Bible I've not seen any footage of
Palestinian people cursing Jewish people
or Israeli people these are people of
God I know these people were blessed by
Allah himself asalam Alum greetings and
peace welcome to the dean sham media
host and I'm with not one two but three
Muslims not just three Muslims but three
Muslims from the three Muslims podcast
this is
the I love you you're doing when I was
ready to talk about it I would
was explaining how much respect I have
for the faith of
[Music]
Islam how you Brothers
doing doing good how are you doing Edie
go introduce yourselves for our audience
yeah my name is fah co-host of the three
Muslims the realest podcast in the
dun my name is anel also know the
co-host of the three Muslims
podcast and my name is Ramy the the
third Muslim here alhamdulillah from the
three Muslims alhamdulillah so you've
been with us before you've been here
before I you about the whole crew now
huh yeah yeah it's good to have you
brother
alhamdulillah so this is uh first time
for you guys in Chicago you've been here
before right yeah passed through Chicago
once yeah how about how about you Ry
yeah actually never been to Chicago at
all so this is a great how's the first
experience amazing alhamdulillah aside
from the gunshots amazing
gunshots shyra sh shy Town sh yeah
alhamdulillah depends where you're at
uhhuh so um how's uh everything going
with you Brothers little little
depressing man with the whole Gaza
situation right now honestly and
sometimes I I catch
myself really complaining about mundane
things in my mind like oh why are things
not this way why are things AR that way
and these are Such trivial matters M and
we're afforded such luxuries today in
the modern world that we forget that
some of these kids they don't even know
if they're going to make it till M yet
the level of n on their face Subhan
Allah they don't fear anything they're
so content no no negative emotion in
their face bro M makes me wonder
like like Allah has an interesting way
of balancing the skills mhm you know so
I don't know when it's when it's going
to be our time I just pray that you know
Allah gives us all ease and a mean eases
the hearts and minds of those oppressed
the most mhm a
mean I want to go ahead and get your
guys reaction uh and I'm going to start
off with this one video because we're
going to talk we're going to be throwing
some words around you might hear Jew
Zionist you might hear uh Christian so
people can see where we're coming from
because Islam is a just way of life and
we don't discriminate against anybody
just because he's of a certain ethnicity
religion we have a way of life that caus
us to be just
across the board so let's kick off and
get your guys reaction to this Muslim
who's actually he's showing some love to
somebody that some people would be like
why is he going that far so let me hear
what you guys have to
[Music]
say
now who was that for people I don't know
they think might that might be just
another Jew who's actually hugging and I
don't know if he was even kissing the
the other Jews what was going on here it
looks like a young Muslim man
appreciating a group of probably
Orthodox Jews who are standing against
Zionism and with the Palestinian people
I can't say I would have behaved any
differently if I if I saw something like
that actually when we were here in uh we
were in Chicago so you would have H you
would have did the same thing almost
probably he's probably overwhelmed with
emotion Louis bro yeah when right before
we we left from St Louis um we sawo at
the burger shop and we saw um a group of
people Marching for Palestine Subhan
Allah and just I so hold on you're
Palestinian also yeah so what you're
saying is you would have done the same
as a Palestinian because what they're
telling us the media is that you want to
your people you're Palestinian you want
to eradicate Jews why would we want to
eradicate Jews the the prophet sallahu
alaihi wasallam he married Jews he lived
with Jews he made peace treaties with
Jews he allowed them to have their own
uh their own culture their own religion
their own courts based on the religion
uh there is no such thing as the
eradication of Jews in Islam and um you
know what I love about so Sean hanity if
he invited you on you'd come on and 100%
100% you know I I will talk to to anyone
Zionist Jewish non-zionist Christian
because this is what Allah tells us to
do in the Quran he says you know discuss
debate with them with um passionate um
with uh with Mercy uh and and hikma I
think or at least with hi with wisdom
yeah with wisdom yes yeah so may Allah
forgive me for quot of the Ayah so this
is what we do as Muslims we we discuss
with all different walks of life all
different people because at the end of
the day we want them to come to Islam
because we believe that's what's best
for them but Allah has given every human
leeway he says you know there's no
compulsion in religion so I don't want
to eradicate anyone no muslim wants to
eradicate anyone we actually want to
establish peace in the earth and we
believe Islam is a way to do that
absolutely uh you wanted to add
something I was going to say a quick uh
Ayah from the Quran Allah says in the
Quran um you know if you kill one
innocent life it's as if you've killed
all of mankind if you save one innocent
life it's as if you've saved all of
mankind so why would we not behave in
accordance to how Allah wants us to
behave first and foremost before how we
want to base on our whims and desires
but but what about if someone pushes
back and says hold on but aren't you the
guys that are saying from The River To
The Sea what does that mean well well I
mean from The River To The Sea just
means that all the occupied Palestinian
land that was stolen from the
Palestinians uh IL legally and given to
um a group of people to make a Jewish
state to the Zionist to make a Jewish
State um will be free inshallah one day
because I'm sure if anyone at home had
their home or their grandparents home or
their great great grandparents home
broken into and stolen for a few decades
maybe a few Generations eventually the
rightful owners will want to take
control of their home their property
again especially when you have um a
group of people who are being persecuted
because it's not just about the land
itself like let's put the land aside for
a second there's a whole demographic of
people who are being oppressed so when
we say from The River To The Sea
Palestine will be free we're not just
talking about the land we're talking
about the people who will no longer be
ethnically cleansed will no longer be
killed or persecuted uh against with
within this aparte state of Israel mhm
that's deep I mean so we just had we
started off with the Muslim was he
kissing he was hugging and he actually
kissed the yeah he I think he kissed the
uh the child yeah yeah uh so that's like
driving some people insane who are
pushing this hate right so the Muslim
showing love you actually as a
Palestinian you're saying that you
actually you probably would have been
doing the same thing giving a hug
absolutely uh we're just dispelling so
much of these uh myths and all of this
uh propaganda that's trying to uh create
this division in fear did you want to
add to that yeah I wanted to ask you how
would you handle the situation I I I
would probably I any because you're
seeing someone coming up who's also
brave enough a lot of these rabbis and
whatnot to speak against oppression so I
I you feel like man this is how all
human beings should be they should be
standing for oppression against
oppression so you're ethnically Bosnian
yes let's say the roles were reversed
here and you got you got a Serb yes
that's you know out here saying I don't
condone whatever happened mhm you know
to Bosnia would you be acting the same
way as his brother was towards us that
show him some love absolutely cuz he's
putting his neck on the line he's
speaking the truth absolutely you don't
continue the cycle of hatred hate hate
breeds hate then that breeds violence
and where we at we're at where we're at
today where do you think this comes from
cuz there's a lot of people
Unfortunately they carry on this cycle
of hatred after generation and
generation mhm I mean I think that's
going away from God it's going away from
because when you're connected to your
creator your creator has certain
attributes he's the most loving the most
just the most kind so when you're just
you're not doing Injustice so when there
is Justice then there's Peace So the
Muslims when Muslims were ruling at that
time Jerusalem
and people can check the history there
was uh often when we talk about it it's
one thing they say oh you guys you know
trying to sugarcoat you trying to change
it but there's actually you can go right
now and go when Muslims conquer
Jerusalem and I was watching actually
this professor American professor and he
was talking about how omad the kff of
Islam when he came we're not even
talking about salahu yet right when he
came on the scene and we won't even go
to Prophet Muhammad because they're
imitating Prophet Muhammad the last
final messenger he was talking about how
the S the um Temple of um of the Jews
was just
over covered with for how many four or
500 years just garbage and he on his own
the Muslim ruler he's removing the
garbage from this the temple and he's
like where the Jews at and they're like
man we threw him
out sparus was it sparus he was the head
um uh PR priest the head um uh patriarch
and he's like um we kicked him out and
and Omar this is the the Muslim ruler
he's like get him back he's like he
brought so many I think uh I don't know
how many 70 80 F and they repopulated
Jerusalem look it this is mindblowing so
how would Muslims be those who want to
eradicate Jews when they're repopulating
Jerusalem Subhan Allah this is never
thought like let me give you guys uh
something else here that we can get into
you guys probably grew up uh like most
of us watched uh no Rambo is Sylvester
Stallone Terminator no one two three how
many of them were there I think there
were three there's a lot of them right
three or four yeah so people know when I
say Arnold S [__] right yeah okay let's
see our friend Arnold why never
again is the rallying Cry of all of the
people who fight to prevent another
Holocaust the amount of millions of
people that died was absolutely
unnecessary and it was something that we
should never ever repeat again what do
you guys
think I uh firstly I I appreciate uh him
for coming out in speaking in this time
it's actually very difficult
unfortunately for a lot of celebrities
namely celebrities uh to speak out in
any regard for the Palestinian people
now although he didn't explicitly
mention Palestine Israel or what's going
on I think it's really big because a lot
of celebrities take the easy route of
just condemning what everyone's calling
a terrorist group but they're not taking
the time to really look into what's
happening on the the the bigger in the
bigger picture so I do appreciate that
he's alluding to something very
important which is this idea of never
again you see during World War II I
can't help but wonder why it took so
long for America to get involved and so
long for the world to acknowledge what
was happening and really really try and
put an end to it
it also makes me wonder what the heck
the the people in Germany were doing if
they were agreeing what with what was
happening or if they were opposing it
and if they didn't oppose it why not and
I ask these questions because when you
look at today what's happening you see a
lot of people denying what's happening
right now you see a lot of people
actually supporting what's happening to
the Palestinians right now this is an
ethnic cleansing that has been going on
for 75 years 75 years 75 years imagine
if you got a bad neighbor like who's
um that neighbor is um parking in your
driveway that neighbor is um leaving the
garbage uncovered maybe and it's
spilling over to yours or right but let
alone someone who's stealing your your
land alone since 1948 yeah here people
would just draw their weapon and say get
off my lawn or you're going to get shot
and some in some cases when they do
shoot they're not even liable but for
some reason when a whole group of people
who have been ethnically cleansed for 75
years fights back they are barbaric they
are evil they are doing evil things
because they're evil people no if Ander
buts I think the UN also gives them
right yeah by law they they have the
right any occupied person has the right
to defend themselves against the
occupier MH and that's just
one let's continue on with Arnold what
you do about the Israel Palestine
question I think that what the Biden
Administration is doing is the right way
to go you know I I think that we have to
acknowledge that Israel was attacked
viciously unprovoked I'm 100% with the
Israelis in this case uh but so but what
this is the thing so what do you guys
think um I think uh
Arnold and I wanted to point this out
and bring this up because he's somebody
who's a legend for many people and I
think he's getting half the story either
he's very ignorant he just doesn't know
and he just following the mainstream
narrative he hasn't taken a deep dive
because or otherwise because we right
now us I don't know if you guys are
paying members to any uh organization in
Palestine are you like you know with any
groups I know I'm not no we're just for
the children I know myself I can't you
know I'm pretty much see you guys on the
same page here um so but he says he
stands he stands
with the the country the IDF these
people who are now committing a genocide
and they also have a two sets of laws
for different peoplethe state so I I'm
just I don't know what you guys think he
he would be someone who' have to answer
for
that what do you
think so first off I'd say that know
Allah knows best anything we say would
just be speculation right we don't know
what's in his
heart uh But first you know from
Wasington these videos you can gather
from it that you know well he's he's a
normal human right he feels looking back
in the past so see what was done to the
Jews from the Germans he himself is
German he sees that and he can is it
sympathize or
empathize sympathizer yeah he can
sympathize because he sees a horrible
thing it's a horrible thing any human
Muslim conds that yeah absolutely
exactly but from what is going on you
can tell that either one like you said
either he's ignorant
or he's bought out he's bought and the
master are falling out my question is
never if he's coming out with this and
he's saying never again my question is
does that include Palestinians or it
doesn't that's my question because if
this is happening in real time right now
and we're saying never again why aren't
people like him stepping up and say hold
on I just said never again so we got to
stop this yeah it's a very good point
and and I think as the brothers
mentioned it's one of two things either
it's ignorance or I don't want to say
bought out but an unwillingness to speak
on it for whatever personal reasons I'm
going to assume it's ignorance I think
most people unfortunately are not
educated on it and I think there has
been a big shift socially in the social
media sphere that brings about a change
in people's mind on the issue so for
Arnold I would I think the question you
posed is very important and I would take
it a step further I would very
specifically are you okay with children
being bombed in the aim of getting out
an enemy thousands of
children I genuinely want to know what
what he has to say about that I believe
I think he's a good guy I think he would
say no genuinely and I think anyone who
says yes um would would very obviously
and quickly switch the narrative if it
was like you know their own people being
bombed if it was their children being
bombed so I think that's why it's
important to to frame this just from
like Dr S Ahmed told us from a
humanitarian perspective this is not
just Arabs this is not just Palestinians
these are human beings imagine if it was
your children uh who grew up in what is
an open air prison and brutal
blockade this is a human thing I like
that this is a humanitarian thing this
is not something that we should be
looking at from that lens of just okay
this is it's like gangs people almost
take it like a gang okay this is not
part of my click so I'm not I mean if
this was the other way around Muslims
also again like you quoted the Ayah
verse from the Quran uh we would step up
and condemn yeah any any group of
people's children just being
indiscriminately bombed and killed yeah
and the crazy thing is is that he said
what he said but if he's paying
attention I mean just recently what was
it the the prime minister of izy said
that they want to Nuke Gaza they're
talking about that now they're talking
about that you tell me if izy was never
provoked if it was never
provoked then why is it that they would
go about doing something like this
because okay if they want to condemn
Kamas understandable but to wipe out an
entire population where more than 95% of
them is going to be civilians innoc
Christians too yeah yeah that's a very
good point and that's something I I
wanted to address the whole idea of
unprovoked when you say unprovoked
that for me shows clear ignorance what
does unprovoked mean unprovoked means I
have no reason no rational cause for me
attacking saying or doing anything
that's what unprovoked means so when you
take a group of people who have been in
an open air prison at at the best open
air prison at the worst a concentration
camp for about 17 years most of people
in that specific group that attacked
Israel are orphans 80% of them are
orphans whose parent parents were killed
by Israel and they themselves grew up in
what is what seems to be a concentration
camp where humanitarian Aid was the only
source of survival for them majority of
the adults were unemployed many kids
expressed no will to live the education
is is completely shot and they are given
below the UN recommended amount of
water many other things I can go into
but for the sake of time I'll leave it
at that is this something that Arnold
would be okay with
Israel doing does he is he aware that
Israel is doing this and when people
when these people lash out and attack to
be clear they tried the peaceful route
in 2018 they got shot literally 50,000
people were shot and injured over 200
people 250 people were killed and Israel
as you reported also targeted
journalists and Medics which is the war
that was the march of return cor Yeah
March of return and that happened in
Gaza just for people to escap those were
those were protesters yeah exactly
peaceful protest journalists uh doctors
Med I mean just you name people in
wheelchairs exactly and and the IDF shot
them um the UN actually specifically
reported they practice shooting from the
knee down but you know what's amazing
they even spun that somehow they always
try to they really King at Deception
yeah spinning things M yeah very true
and keeping things as quiet as possible
for example when after this happened I
believe it was afterwards the gazin
actually went to the icj which is a
branch of the UN to pursue a legal case
against Israel they tried peaceful
didn't work they tried legal and then
the Trump Administration threatened to
seize the assets to the UN and then the
whole case was swatted and mind you un
is the organization that reported the
war crimes Israel committed so all it
would take for them is to basically take
it to to court and then boom it's all
done it's all said and done the case is
over and we know who's guilty so when
that was shut down they tried the
peaceful route didn't work they tried
the legal route didn't work what is left
for these people in this concentration
camp to do I'm not saying that what they
did is is good I'm not saying that I
stand by it but to Arnold Arnold or
anyone else who thinks that this is bad
ask yourself what the heck would you do
if your parents were murdered by Israel
and you were raised into a concentration
camp where you're wandering front to
back end to end literally just waiting
to die what's this thing with the
permits pardon me where okay so the
water's controlled yeah electricity is
controlled they often talk about
building they left 2005
but then you have the everything is in
the other side's control like if you
want to build a house you want to do
anything fishing you want to go fish you
can't like you got to you have to get
permits and then there this game that
they play I mean if you want to go here
let's say in America you want to go and
build your house you saved up money you
want to go ahead and build your dream
house and now you fulfilled all the
requirements and you went to the zoning
commission is and they keep giving you
to run around years go by you can't get
the permit and then they're just doing
it because you're of a certain ethnicity
you're a certain religion and you can't
get that perit because of that but
that's what's happening is that correct
is that something did I explain it well
how how does it work where you cannot
fish you cannot build you can't do
anything because you can't get the per
that if you build something and then
they tear it down it's like oh we just
did because they didn't have permits
yeah it's a game they play 100% And this
I think is Israel's way of getting
around their atrocities they give you a
way and then make that way also
impossible so they'll say if you want to
fish you fish you just have to get a
permit and then they'll make it nearly
impossible for you to get that permit so
then you can't fish and like you
mentioned the water is controlled the
electricity is controlled and they will
say this is because we want to defend
ourselves against Hamas if they get
access to certain resources they will
just attack Us in XY Z but this what
this amounts to is collective punishment
which is a war crime it's at the I want
to be very specific with my wording at
the best best case scenario it's a war
crime at the worst case scenario it's
it's a genocide and anywhere in between
would be what's called a crime against
humanity in international law
so they will do this and then that's in
Gaza if you go over to the West Bank
actually maybe even a few years ago and
today you will have supreme court
eviction notices sent to people who have
been in and whose families for
Generations have been in that specific
house on that specific piece of land for
Generations they will see a court
supreme court eviction notice saying
they need to leave to make room for
Israeli settlers who have never stepped
foot inside of Palestinian land whose
ancestors never stepped foot in
Palestinian land and the people who have
been there for Generations are kicked
out for them and then if if people do
want to live within the land they also
have to get a permit which again is also
nearly impossible to get I completely
forgot this I don't know who said this
but right now in in uh is Israel I can
say this right not an issue I already
said call us you can't get a blood
test it's illegal to get a blood test
because if if all the citizens were to
get blood tests it would actually show
that they're actually not from the land
or they have ancestry from all different
places DNA test a DNA test yeah ancestry
test the test
Yeah well yeah that brings me to my next
question so that's how that's that right
of return
where you had people who for Generation
generations and even they take DNA tests
they even connected to the canites
they're connected to this land and they
can't return but someone from Brooklyn
New York can come in you saw the famous
clip that went around and said if I'm
not stealing it someone else stealing it
yeah so that person is not even
connected but he says look I got from
3,000 years ago I got a I got a uh
religious Birthright to
it do bro yeah this this is this is a
hilarious claim to me because where does
it come from it comes from the Bible and
now my question to them is will they use
the Bible to justify capital punishment
will they use the Bible to justify other
laws will they use the Bible to justify
slavery again will they use the Bible in
these ways no so why are they selective
with what they choose from the Bible
then you have Orthodox Jews that say
listen we've been expelled by God from
the land we have no right to return so
therefore it doesn't belong to the
Palestinians and then you have people
who are logical about it and they say
listen the Canaanites were there before
the children of Israel and the
Canaanites are like you mentioned uh
genetically closest to the Arabs
nowadays therefore actually Lebanese
people specifically so they would have
to give heah the land if they really
really believe this principle yeah I've
had I've had um Israeli Jewish friends
who are totally against and this what
blows my mind when you see people like
that like M PID he was an IDF Soldier
his uh father was a general in the
Israeli Army his grandfather was someone
who was there signing the original
Constitution to when the first was
started the state and he's somebody
who's totally took a deep dive totally
against what's going on and he's
speaking the truth then you have other
Rabbi Rabbi Weiss and uh Rabbi Shapiro
I've had on a program and these are
people and I think he he led
15,000 one of the biggest Gatherings of
uh of rabbis and Jews who are totally
against it so it's not Muslims against
Jew this is uh this this is what called
um Zionism Zionist movement and these
are people who are following the
Theodore hzo he's the prophet of this
who was an atheist he was someone didn't
even believe in God and I feel that you
see a lot of these people hiding behind
religion they're not really even
following the true teachings of Moses
true teachings of the prophets no this
is like good versus evil at this point
and you know I'm not surprised that the
puppets that are running these countries
you know the prophet warned about a day
like this when truth will be like
falsehood and falsehood will be like
truth we had uh she omaran on the
podcast uh yesterday and right before
you know we had the podcast I was on the
way to pick up Ramy and anill and I saw
this one uh this article because a lot
of these puppets they deny all the the
death count you know what I mean so it
was released you know they had the names
of all the the casualties all of those
that were killed in Philistine and it
said something like they were
categorized by age right so you'll
basically see um those that didn't even
make it to one years like one year old
and their age so shows zero because it's
in the months and it was basically just
six pages of just those before like
infants before the age of one before it
even reached one-year-old and just one
after another after another and then
they deny oh you know it's actually
inflated it's not actually you know it's
self-defense so it's like it's it's
delusion and this is this has been
genuinely I believe in the modern day
one of the biggest I guess you could say
scams where the media has hijacked the
narrative and I believe that they
overplayed their hand and people are
waking up and they don't want to they
don't want to take this anymore honestly
you see them um affiliating like on the
mainstream media as sympathizers
to um a certain group which most like
myself I had no idea about many of these
groups and
I would often say when they say this
name I say humus you know humus like we
eat the hummus because I like most we
don't know and then you have people who
are protesting and then they try to
connect them uh to a particular group
and whatnot um but would you say this is
a deliberate attempt to confuse the
situation because what I mean I see is
and most people see what do you guys
think is people are out there because
they're seeing the injustices are
happening they've done some homework and
they're seeing the L the land grab
they're seeing injustices happening apar
tide Nelson Mandela called it Jimmy
Carter called it uh and Del what is Tutu
you know so many people who are sincere
who they are following their heart they
have a conscience exactly and many
Israelis many Jewish people Israeli
historians uh Amnesty International
human rights organizations has condemned
this as a part-time state so they're
like hold on
we're seeing it in real time we don't
want to be people who just are complicit
in this they're getting out there and
they're protesting and now they're
trying to shut this down even and
they're kind to confuse the situation
and make it seem like these people are
extremists what are your thoughts on
that I do want to just quickly say that
regarding this whole mainstream media I
think that we live in a day and age now
where after 2020 2021 2022 not going to
mention what the things happened uh in
you know government control but people
are kind of waking up and and really
doing the research for themselves I
think you guys would agree with that and
that's why I'm there the thing with Elon
Musk it's like we we never really know
his pure intentions but him taking over
Twitter turning into X I can guarantee
you at least one thing that from what's
apparent there's a lot of free speech on
X compared to mainstream media there's a
brother by the name of Jackson Hinkle
who I believe he's a he's a not far
right but at least right leaning uh
republican from America and he's posting
actual real news about Pro Palestinians
every single day and I think he went
from zero to like 2 million followers on
X in like a matter of two weeks this
type of stuff would never happen this is
the same guy that got banned on YouTube
right so I think they're working
overtime to make sure that the real news
doesn't come out but it's going to
eventually come out at the end of the
day and we just pray that it's going to
be in this life and not in the Hereafter
mhm yeah and and to answer your question
to put it in the words of the political
scientist Norman finlin Israel's a
lunatic state when you have a lunatic
the the the this is a Jewish academic
right family was in the Holocaust
Survivor of his family so he's someone
who's actually Jewish background
speaking up on behalf of the injustices
yeah and it it to talk about him for a
brief moment because I do admire him a
lot for for these reasons nor what's say
his name again Norman finlin nor people
going to look him up Norman finlin yeah
he's been researching the topic for 40
years and it broke my heart when I heard
him on a sure recently say that even at
some point even he lost hope at some
point even he moved on to different
topics and he said he was ashamed to
admit that um this is someone who's very
has very close connection very personal
connection to the the topic of genocide
the topic of putting people into
blockades and concentration camps and
cleansing them based on ethnicity
referring to them as as human animals
and insects and all the stuff as Israel
and their actual spokes people have
referred to Palestinians as so when you
have a lunatic the the the easiest
softest
thing the least punitive crime they
could commit is lying is distorting
misrepresenting so when you have these
Israeli spokes persons whether they're
in Israel or people like Ben here in the
west paring the same nonsensical
statements like Israel has a right to
defend itself when legally they they are
the occupier which makes it legally
impossible for them to even be defending
themselves um I think it's very obvious
that they are the Liars in the situation
let's just look at the evidence like
let's look at the footage I have yet to
see a single Israeli baby killed I love
LOE seeing something like that I don't
want to see it and thank God I haven't
alhamdulillah I have seen hundreds of
babies on the Palestinian side killed
blown to pieces I've seen severed
arms the sides of my hand so I've seen
we have all seen grotesque things that
Israel's done to the Palestinian people
I don't want to see evidence of of the
other
side but when Israel's lies time and
time again you can't help but demand
some kind of evidence to substantiate
what they have been saying especially
when other organizations report
otherwise the BBC was on the ground they
said we have no evidence of 40
decapitated babies in the they were in
the city in the town where allegedly
happened yeah we don't have a problem I
don't think any Muslim has a problem
condemning or being repulsed or saddened
or however you want to put it totally
against seeing any Israeli babies or
children I mean this is something that
um obviously because of our religion
because of the justice of Islam Islam is
totally against this you open up with
that verse from the Quran so we don't
have a problems we we don't want babies
killed from any side but it's
interesting now they're even using the
Bible and you see this um term uh amales
they're trying to
dehumanize the Palestinians there and
you have and I'm just surprised you even
have rabbis who are coming out and
justifying this Zionist I would say
Zionist rabbis because I I don't think
this is something that
um any sane person person of God Justice
love Mercy is going to um and I think
this is honestly one of the verses that
has been because we know the Bible has
been altered and changed the Quran tells
us this and that's what the Quran was
sent but we'll get into that was um one
of one of my next Clips here I want to
get your guys reaction go ahead yeah
before we go into the next one the thing
that I want to bring up kind of going
back to the Germans right what they did
the craziest thing that Hitler ever did
was not kill millions of Jews the
craziest thing he ever did was
convincing an entire nation that they
needed to be
exterminated and if you look at what's
happening right now anyone put all the
things that you're hear aside and just
look at what's happening right now and
then ask yourself the
question this whole nation of Israel and
now this whole nation outside of Israel
like in America or anywhere in the world
really anyone who's being exposed to the
mainstream media there's this narrative
and everyone is being convinced that
Israel is the one that is the victim
that they're the ones that are the
victim when clearly like it shows and
you have like you said you have these
rabbis you have these people who are
saying that these Palestinians are like
rats that are like the what was the word
you use the amalik yeah amalik yes and
that they all need to be
exterminated well they're
convincing an entire generation that
these people need to be exterminated
from the face of the earth now you
answer or I as a question to you I ask
the question to everyone watching this
is that not the same thing that Hill
did yeah so you see that projection now
it's like they projecting it and what
they because they're also trying to flip
it saying these guys are Nazis and
whatnot and they're projecting this I
mean I don't think I think it's safe to
say you would agree I mean the the
Muslims down there the Christians
Palestinians they would love to live
together with their neighbors in peace
just don't steal my home in my land
absolutely it's very simple I mean would
you you're Palestinian would you would
you is that can I say that is that fair
would you agree with that absolutely
absolutely again like we Palestinians
Arabs Muslims specifically we don't have
any problem with Jewish people we love
them just like anyone else like they
they have lived with Muslims alongside
Muslims very peacefully for hundreds of
years there have been times like you
mentioned om he he sent a Jewish revert
this is how specific he was he sent a
Jewish revert to Islam to find 80 Jewish
families to bring back to Jerusalem
after the Romans expelled them you don't
do this to people you hate you don't do
this to people you want to exterminate
that's deep man that's that what I was
talking about yeah and you were
absolutely right about that um but on
what Israel is doing now this is this is
one of the main tactics of a liar um if
they have committed a crime against you
they will turn around and and accuse you
of that crime cuz no sane person would
ask if you committed the crime that I
committed like people should have more
shame than that but that is what Israel
has done time and time again Amnesty
International 22 days of death and
destruction they reported that Hamas did
not use any human Shields but Israel
used Palestinians as human Shields I Ur
everyone to look it up you have the the
West Bank right yeah now what they're
doing there there's not this um this
resistance group is not there not at all
so what what are they doing there
they're coming in you had I think there
was like before all of this happened I
think you had one Palestinian a day was
dying yeah was that the number every day
there was a Palestinian dying yeah and
and more thrown in prisons let me tell
you what they were doing what they were
doing in the West Bank is exposing their
true colors because when they do what
they're doing in Gaza and they say we're
not ethnically cleansing we're not
causing a genocide we're not trying to
steal more land um even though they've
been talking about it forever when you
look at the West Bank that's exactly
what they're doing there's no Hamas as
you mentioned there's no terrorist group
there the most violent people there are
if anything are the IDF who break into
people's homes they break into one home
they jump from one roof to another go
through that home and then leave they
practice this routinely every day and
every night as well they're the most
violent people in that land like I
mentioned these people are sent Court
Supreme Court eviction notices just to
boot them out of their home to make room
for Israeli settlers where do they go
Lord knows they don't know where they're
going to go Israel doesn't care where
they go so they are very clearly just
trying to impede more on Palestinian see
if you just said that as a Palestinian
people like he's lying he's not telling
the truth but this is act what you're
saying this is IDF the soldiers are
saying yeah that there's there's a
website called breaking the silence
where they speak about all of their
atrocities committed some of them let me
add don't say this because their
Humanity finally kicked in they treat it
as interviews they some of there are
people sitting by 4K cameras kind of
like in this setting where they just
talk about doing grow I don't want to
get anything demonetized but they do
very grotesque things to Palestinians
using
flamethrowers and um assaulting them in
various degrading ways so they are very
vocal they themselves are say like
imagine I came on air I'm like I I
killed this person I shot that first IED
like admitting it blatantly as if I'm
proud of it that's what they do
routinely unfortunately all right let's
go to the uh next video so we'll often
see one thing happening but I was uh
very very elated to see another side
that we are not seeing because Allah is
the best of planners Allah plans they
plan Allah plans and Allah is the best
of planner so there's things that are
happening that we just um we don't see
the whole picture we just see a part of
it so I'm going to get you guys reaction
to uh to this 100% feel comfortable
saying that what's happening now is the
Palestinian people is another Holocaust
and they're still saying
alhamdulillah not yet alhamdulillah alul
Muslim Palestinians still seeing them
say Allah is all
knowing Palestinians are doing
everything that was described job doing
in the
Bible I've have not seen any footage of
Palestinian people cursing Jewish people
or Israeli people these are people of
God I know these people were blessed by
Allah himself yeah hold fa
is with such an indominable hope they
don't give up about this his life okay
the only thing these people fear is
Allah that's it if this is the campaign
to to get Nations to be Islamic it's
doing it I've been shocked to my core as
the faith Muslim people have what is
happening in Palestine has opened my
eyes to the beauty of Islam that's
something that people don't get to see
often definitely not here in the west
into the Bible asking logical questions
were not allowed when I read through the
Quran I see logic and Divinity brought
together result of that is on social
media I have seen so many
people picking up the Quran and reading
it through you know this entire thing
with Palestine so many more people are
learning about Islam so many more people
are reading the Quran you got to have a
lot of people turning to Islam soon it's
happening again it's like all these
people I see Quan B Club I see people
deciding to convert to Islam because
they're like well what what is really
going on here I just bought my first
copy of the Quran I got the Quran I
started reading the Quran it's my day
two in reading the Quran so I got see
how these
pal literally are thanking God seeing
the
brave Palestine people as they're losing
everything so much faith and peace while
their families are being murdered States
we need a lot more empathy and
understanding of Muslims in the Arab
world I need to know what y'all foot in
Islam okay I just from reading the
second sura I'm like I get it I
understand why there's such a steadfast
Faith to anyone that follows Islam being
shown just how wrong we were about this
faith and how rich how like how deep and
just the language of it ah how fluid and
beautiful it is we've been lied to the
Western people and and I took my shahada
I feel tremendous peace and I'm going to
be reading it forever
Subhan did you guys see that yeah
absolutely bro yeah Subhan Allah Subhan
Allah um these people right now are
acting as as as the pillars you know in
in the Muslim Community may Allah have
mercy on them grant them the highest
levels of J and continue to make them an
inspiration for us um something that
umman mentioned on podcast that we did
with him was uh something that was sent
to him and was I'm going to paraphrase a
bit along the lines of that you know
basically they have the right upon us or
for us uh to be happy to see us you know
thriving and all that stuff and and they
have we also have a right towards them
that we don't forget about them you know
in in in our joy in our good times that
you know we have to speak out for them
and
hamdulillah they have been like
tremendous like people think that we're
doing something for for them you know I
I swear they're doing way more for us
they they I swear they're doing so much
more for me than I could ever do for
them may Allah have mercy on them and
bless them and um I have seen a lot of
people on Tik Tok just you know just
scrolling through I see people doing
live Quran sessions and reading the
Quran more all because these amazing men
and women are leading by example that is
deep yeah you know how many non-muslims
when westerners looked into Islam after
9/11 I think it's a it's a cask effect
and the master falling as always says
you know he led theba in the St Louis
mjid and he was saying that all this did
was just expose everyone's true
intention you know to the masses because
they're going and looking to see what
does the Quran say exactly smart person
be like okay let's see what's the Quran
say for myself they know the media lies
and they're like wow they're just blown
away and they start like talking about
you know how the Quran is beautiful how
was this how was that and you seen I
mean you recently not too long ago also
had a similar experience right what was
uh we had your story you're someone who
came to Islam how long's it been now
three four
years two years it's been a little over
three years three years around three
years yeah little over three years can
you relate also
like yeah I can it's it's very beautiful
to see something like that especially
when the woman says
that these people speaking about the
Palestinians that they don't care about
this life they just care about Allah
yeah you heard that huh and like I hear
that bro
and it it makes me look at my own life
and like how I make mistakes
and yeah really um it it's deep man I
mean you see like B bombs are falling
falling on them and we're over here
complaining about this that and the
other and it's it's a shame yeah yeah
may Allah forgive us mean a mean bro
just that may Allah keep our hearts
alive I feel it man this is uh amazing
and you see like how how they're talking
about um the woman's like the woman's
like she's not even uh they're not even
cursing I don't hear them even cursing
uh Jews I don't do you hear say that I
haven't heard one video curses you I I
haven't heard one of them like you know
you would imagine they're like cursing F
this F that in the language I mean you
speak the Palestinian right I mean the
Palestinian right Arabic I mean you you
see of course the sadness is there of
course you have emotions and everything
but most of them are saying let say say
God is one say there's nothing worthy of
worship but God the kala right you see
him saying
that means there's nothing where they
worship but God and um and then they go
back and some of them are even accepting
Islam and why the question for for
anybody why would you if the mainstream
media is telling you these are um
sympathizers to a barbaric way of life
and their animals this day and other but
then the smart people they're going and
investigating and here's the reactions
we got right here here's the reactions
and these are just the people these are
note these are just the people that came
out how many people are camera shy don't
operate with you know Tik Tock or any of
these how many of them are there huh
I'll never forget bro it's I think this
was something that she Omar was saying
that if if you have a problem with Islam
and Islam doesn't make sense to you then
you're going to convince yourself that
Islam doesn't make sense period and that
it doesn't make sense to anybody but
it's it has nothing to do with Islam has
everything to do with you you have a
personal obligation not even as you know
a Muslim or a non-muslim but just as a
human being to just wake up and do your
damn research like it shouldn't be that
difficult everybody has that personal
obligation to do that because we live in
a world today where truth is quite
literally being portrayed as falsehood
and falsehood is being you know shoved
down our throats as truth and I believe
that as a man as a woman as a Muslim as
a non-muslim we're all going to die it's
guaranteed and Allah says in the Quran
that on that day even Shan the Devil
Himself he's not going to co-sign for
our mistakes he's not going to take any
accountability we can't diffuse anything
and be a victim on that day and even
blame the Devil
Himself so I don't understand why people
can't just wake up and and re and again
at the end of the day that's why Allah
says in the Quran like it's not up to
you oh Prophet Allah guides who he Wills
you know you can just give them the
message you can take them to the water
you can't make them drink so it's
unfortunate but it warms my heart you
know seeing all these brothers and
sisters in that Tik Tok compilation that
you show show us right now Eddie that
there's still so many sincere people
withas like they want it they want the
truth and I'm sure you know back in the
Jah all of us we can relate to this that
there's a turning point where we just
wanted the truth and once it clicks it
clicks once you hit that five out of
five you know in your Salah you don't go
back M it's just clearheaded you know
and I pray that Allah can give that to
everyone and anybody watching you know
the only thing that I can recommend you
is to read the Quran you know if you
don't know Arabic obviously get the
clear Quran or an English translation
that you you know that you prefer and
just start with that you know this is
what happened with brother an over here
who's a revert with myself and Ramy were
born Muslims but we came on to it of our
own you know volition later in our life
same with you
obviously
alhamdulillah Subhan Allah um Allah
alhamdulillah he intends for us ease you
know intends for us goodness and he says
um he says indeed after hardship there
is ease um which shows that with with
any kind of difficulty Calamity there
will be some kind of ease some kind of
goodness that comes of it aldah whether
in this life or the
next Allah he also tells us that the
prophet is is an excellent example for
us and we can see that these people are
really embodying the sun of the prophet
and the sunah of of you know um the the
the real Muslim
alhamdulillah and we see the effects of
that there there are people who accepted
just because of the character of the
prophet and there's one video I saw on
Tik Tok that didn't make it into the the
compilation cuz it was posted literally
yesterday or maybe even earlier today um
one one woman who's looking into Islam
she was crying and she said I found this
verse in the
Quran I'm reading the Quran and I'm
tearing up
because I've been so worried about the
Palestinian people and especially the
kids who've been dying and it says here
in the the
Quran in uh
2145 and it's the
section 154 do not say that those who
are killed in God's cause are dead they
are alive but you are not aware of
it we shall surely certainly test you
with fear and hunger and loss of
property lives and crops give good news
to those who endure with
fortitude why does this just
give me so much
peace those who say when Afflicted with
a Calamity we belong to God and to him
we shall
return are the ones who will have
blessings and mercy from their Lord it
is they who are on the right
path this is exactly what the people in
Palestine are
doing
they keep thanking God when everything
is going wrong and we can't even thank
God when everything is going
right we have a lot to
learn or Allah says do not say about
those who died in the cause of Allah
that they're dead he says rather there
with Allah receiving his his
provisioning Subhan Allah and I think
for her it
clicked that this is why the people of
are so steadfast on Islam this is why
they're not you know um turning against
God asking why did God do this to me and
instead they're happy because this
beautiful religion from the creator
gives us the reassurance that every
human being is looking for we're
insecure people you don't know why
you're here unless you have Islam you
don't know what you're doing here you
don't know where you came from why
you're here where you're going and that
is a very insecure state to be in and
insecurity will always breed you know
chaos um um afterwards so alhamdulillah
for Islam and um alhamdulillah for the
brother here Allah bless them to say if
you feel you know like you're back on 10
do you want to share what you going to
say if you feel okay I was just going to
say man and forgive me I I don't I don't
usually cry soong no no I felt I felt it
I feel you man when I when I first saw
that it was uh you
know us off in our hearts I mean I mean
it's a blessing I mean it's just crazy
to see because you have the verse in the
Quran where Allah says that indeed they
plan but indeed Allah plans and Allah
plans is greater yes
and something that I
learned a long time ago is that the only
way that we as humans we can connect the
dots is by looking back looking at
what's already happened and the only
person that can connect the dots looking
forward is
Allah and when we hear this Ayah in the
Quran like we understand it yes but now
we're seeing it and we're seeing these
people what they're going through and
what Ramy said how they're doing more
for us than we're doing for them you
know like what they're going through the
daa that they're giving to all these
people that are not Muslims what they're
making actual Muslims realize and just
wake up and move away from this dun from
this life and get back closer to Allah
like it's is to me that that's it's a
very very beautiful thing to see like
again like my heart really goes out to
these
people and anyone in the right state of
mind would want this to stop right but
as a Muslim say that part again anyone
in their right state of mind huh anyone
in the right State of Mind absolutely
anyone the right state of mind so and
that's pretty much it that's what I want
to right state of mind and and and if
the heart's not uh totally black right
yes is it's a like the the Hadith where
the Prophet said says that in the piece
of body or in the body there's a piece
of Flesh that if it's good then verely
is the rest and that piece of flesh is
the
heart and does Allah not say in the
Quran that it's not the eyes that are
blind but it's the hearts MH these
people they see it man they see what's
going on don't think that they don't but
there's a spiritual disease in their
heart they can't comprehend right from
wrong and you know may Allah guide them
to the point where they do because we
need a world where as cliche as it
sounds man but it is a domino effect and
I believe that these yes you know we
have to abide by the the rulings of
Allah you know we can't be uh in
incorrect hijab shouting at these
rallies you get what I mean but we have
to do something and that's what she Omar
was saying we have to be loud indoors on
point with our Salah on point with our I
right and we have to be louded out there
and it's with this that that Allah will
inshallah give us salvation you know
inshallah um guys you actually both
sparked um a thought in my head
alhamdulillah um it's it's difficult for
us when we see these things we want to
look away we want to turn away
and I want to give a message to everyone
who's watching who sees the stuff
happening and wants to turn away wants
to get away go back to their work their
daily jobs as if nothing's happening
these people have no choice but to deal
with it you're just seeing it they're
living it you can turn off your phone
they can't turn off what's going on with
them
so to make it simple I will say that
these people have a right over us for
the Muslim we have an obligation to
enjoin good and forbid evil and to be
there to uphold the rights of Muslims
and to uphold the dignity and the honor
of Muslims and at the end of the day if
we are not going to be there to stand up
for what is right what is just whether
it's a Muslim or a Christian or an
atheist or a Jew even if it's a Zionist
whose rights are being taken from them
if we're not going to be the ones to go
and make sure they get their rights who
will do it definitely not Israel and
definitely not America so it's up to us
as human beings at the very least as
Muslims alhamdulillah but extend it to
everyone as human
beings if you want to see a world of
good then you have to enjoin that good
yourself and if you want to see a world
without evil then you have to forbid
that evil yourself and I wanted to add a
note to that bro just like that was
beautiful and it was it was necessary
that we all hear that message and to add
to that uh wonderful note it breaks my
heart amidst this genocide going on
YouTube and I see Brothers Muslim
Brothers unfortunately making drama and
reaction videos on other Muslim Brothers
a coming for
another we're picking faults at valid
difference in opinion
in yet we can't even unite against the
common enemy isn't that pathetic that
we're out here making videos oh message
to this message to that you know I see
this in the the daene
unfortunately but can we not just unite
for once like is that too much to ask in
the da scene because we're the creators
at the end of the day we're the ones
that make these videos and
we're the ones that have a platform and
Allah has given us that platform it's
not it's not a right it's a privilege uh
so and and it's a responsibility at the
end of the day um we've been given this
and I believe that we be questioned more
about how we use this
platform if all the Muslims United you
know two billion plus this is what's
reported right all the people that all
the reverts AL they can't even declare
that they're Muslim because their
parents might kick them out how many
Muslims do you think there are probably
way more than that if we all United as
one as one um right as the prophet
mentioned one body do you not think that
we can actually make legitimate
significant change but Shan will come to
you and tell you your individual efforts
will make no no no difference that
little $5 that you were going to donate
will make no difference your one Dua
will not change the world it's already
decreed yes it's already decreed but do
we not have to work for it that's why
there's a difference uh we were
listening to this HBA in the car uh and
they were saying that there's a
difference between and in
Arabi is just having this Blind Faith
I'm not going to lift a finger I'm
waiting for that job but I'm not going
to go apply I'm waiting for change I'm
not doing anything
but is when you do everything that you
can do in your power and responsibility
as a Muslim and you put your trust in
Almighty Allah and that's the level that
I pray that we can all make Dua to get
to
mean thank you guys L was going to say
is that it's a shame that as Muslims you
know we had to get this far in order for
us to start you know really coming
together and you guys see you know you
probably check what's going on in
Palestine and it's just it gets worse
and worse as time
progresses and as it's getting worse you
notice that the Muslims are letting go
of these dumb things and actually
starting to come together so I
understand where you're coming from bro
it's just a shame that if there is no
difficult thing happening right now then
you have Muslims over here trying
to correct oh brother you you know when
when you pray you uh your foot has to be
like this when you sit on it and your
foot has to be turned this way not this
like come on brother there's more
important things you know so I think the
biggest call to action that we can give
all the viewers
is to just quit playing around come
together and like we were saying be the
the voice for the Palestinians cuzz
without us on the
outside they won't have they won't have
anyone to speak for them so may Allah
make it easy for us and I just wanted to
say that that was that was brilliant bro
it's it's not that Hal har and doesn't
matter or it's unimportant of course
it's an essential pillar of our faith
not one of the Five Pillars before he
all come after me but it's an essential
Foundation but when you look at the
Quran being revealed first numerous
years there was no
it was just it was manners being a good
human being first and foremost if you're
a Muslim you have to be a good human
being because if you're not then are you
really a m that's up to Allah not for me
to judge but I think it's absolutely
important to be really looking at your
own self in the mirror before pointing
at The Faults of your own brothers and
sisters you know and I think that a lot
of people Unfortunately they project
just like the mainstream media now when
they're reminding you too much maybe
they're the one that need the the
reminder the most you
know thank you so much Eddie for having
us alhamdulillah again I want to say may
Allah bless the people of phe bless
everyone who's enjoying good and
forbidding evil may Allah accept those
who died in Gaza and in the West Bank as
and granted the highest levels of Jenna
allow them to in their families to
reunite and and bless these amazing
people for being such Inspirations for
all of us nice having the three three
Muslims thank you so much for having us
it's been a pleasure you guys have been
immensely hospitable so may Allah reward
you a mean a mean aan thank you guys
what are we eating tonight bro Persian
huh Persian
food yeah all right let's get it let's
do it all right brother
thank this guy right here this guy's
trying to build a dawa Center in our
country I'm not talking to you right now
you're a solo you're trying to build a
DA Center here Islam is violent asalam
brothers and sisters this is exactly why
we need the dean Center because we have
over 300 million Americans who know
nothing about Islam like this guy hey
you want to have a talk yeah this guy's
trying to build a DA sent in our country
Surah 9 is the most violent chapter of
the Quran the dean Center will be a
source of light a mega daa Center an
educational center helping our brothers
and sisters in humanity truly understand
Islam and Muslims and brothers and
sisters remember the great rewards of
just guiding one person in humanity to
the truth is better than everything in
this dun so get in on all the rewards
and blessings click the link below
donate right now may God Almighty Allah
reward all of
[Music]
you I cannot leave without giving you a
gift if you're not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead and visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum